The problem I'd like to tell you about is motivated by an actual study
the University of California Berkeley,
which many years back wanted to know whether it's admissions procedure
is gender biased.
I looked at various admission statistics to understand whether than admissions policies
had a preference for a certain gender.
And while the numbers I'll be giving you are not the exact same that UC Berkeley found,
the paradox is indeed the same and is often called, "Simpson's Paradox."
I'm just giving you a simplified version of the problem.
Here is the data.
Among male students, we find that from 900 applicants in major A 450 are admitted.
Please tell me what the acceptance rate is in percent.